Task Force X did its job and made the world
safe…for now.
Suicide Squad may be a critical punching bag,
but it still has its rewards for comic book
diehards—including a bunch of references
and homages for the faithful to enjoy.
So let's pick up Harley Quinn's mallet and
start smashing some Suicide Squad Easter eggs.
Watching The Watchmen
Remember when Deadshot looks into the clothing
store window and starts moping out about his
daughter?
That huge yellow smiley face behind the mannequins
wasn't there by chance.
In DC Comics' 2016 Rebirth event, the world
of the Watchmen officially entered the DC
Universe.
And it may only be a matter of time before
that happens in the movies as well, with this
and similar Easter eggs like the Watchmen
graffiti in Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice
helping to set up in the inevitable.
Frosty Flunky
While the Joker mostly employs nameless goons,
one of his men sports a name tag reading "Mr.
Frost."
Brian Azzarello's graphic novel Joker was
told from the perspective of Jonny Frost,
who goes from being Joker's chauffeur to becoming
his top man.
The scenes of Harley shaking her stuff in
a nightclub and Mr. Frost being the Joker's
number one guy are likely both inspired by
Azzarello's story.
High-Rise Tribute
This blink-and-you'll-miss-it Easter egg is
pretty easy to figure out if you know your
DC history: the giant building the team infiltrates
to rescue Amanda Waller is named after comics
writer John Ostrander.
While Ostrander didn't create the original
team that debuted in 1959, he did come up
with the modern Suicide Squad in 1987.
What Goes Around, Comes Around
When Captain Boomerang convinces Slipknot
his neck-bomb is a dud, the scene mirrors
what happens in the comics after Boomerang
tells Slipknot that their wrist-mounted bombs
were fake.
Of course, in the comics, the bomb only blew
off his arm...instead of his head.
Eh you win some, you lose some.
Dancing With The Devil In The Pale Moonlight
Some people might prefer Harley Quinn's classic
black-and-red costume, but at least her original
outfit appears in the movie.
When the squad prepares to go to Midway City,
Harley pulls out a familiar-looking outfit
but tosses it aside in favor of something
a bit more revealing.
"We're bad guys, it's what we do."
We also got to see Margot Robbie don the classic
Harley getup in a flashback sequence, which
recreates Alex Ross's iconic cover to 1999's
Batman: Harley Quinn.
Time Away From Mr. J
After being let down by the Joker a few times
throughout the movie, Harley appears to have
some second thoughts about her maniacal boyfriend.
"Huh?"
Her budding friendship and flirtatious chemistry
with Will Smith's Deadshot is a callback to
what happens in the comics—and the animated
feature Batman: Assault on Arkham, where things
occasionally got hot, heavy, and downright
weird between these two Batman villains:
"I got an itch I thought you could help me
scratch Cowboy."
Flashback
This Easter egg is kind of obvious, but it's
still pretty awesome.
Captain Boomerang's introductory flashback
sequence shows a jewelry store robbery, in
which his getaway is stopped by Ezra Miller’s
Flash.
It's only right that Captain Boomerang is
thwarted by the Scarlet Speedster, since he
first appeared as a Flash villain way back
in 1960.
In an interview with Collider, director David
Ayer revealed that this scene was shot while
Suicide Squad was in post-production.
The scene was directed by Batman v. Superman
director, Zack Snyder while he was filming
Justice League.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know if there
are any other Suicide Squad Easter eggs that
should've made the list...